[Music]
on this Tuesday night fighting to phase
out fossil fuels critics accuse leaders
at cop 28 of copping out our leaders
keep on destroying our planet I talked
to a Canadian climate scientist who says
not all hope is lost we can't do this
alone but I know that we can do it
together Canada votes to demand an
Israeli ceasefire in Gaza hostages must
be released
immediately civilians must be protected
the campaign to free hostages heads to
Ottawa could I have my boy back and
busted how Smugglers tried to hide
several tons of cocaine from the
cops global national with Donna FZ good
evening and thanks for joining us
pressure is mounting on Israel for an
immediate humanitarian ceasefire in Gaza
more than 3/4s of the 193 member UN
General Assembly including Canada voted
today to stop the bombardment though the
resolution is non-binding and you the US
Israel's biggest Ally voted against it
Canada Australia and New Zealand signed
a joint statement today saying the price
of defeating Hamas cannot be the
continuous suffering of Palestinian
civilians prime minister Justin Trudeau
says he spoke with Israel's prime
minister today we are committed to
working uh with Partners in the region
and around the world towards an enduring
two- State solution with the future of
Israelis and Palestinians in mind Canada
is joining the international call for
human humanitarian
ceasefire Canada had until now been
careful not to use the word ceasefire
Israel's ambassador to Canada calls
today's change in tone
disappointing I think that it has
changed for the for the worst in
Israel's eyes because calling for a
ceasefire in a situation that Israel is
forced into a war actually does not
strengthen us um as I said it emboldens
the
terrorists the heads of several of the
world's largest humanitarian
organizations say they have seen nothing
like Israel's Siege on Gaza in a guest
essay published in the New York Times
They write the atrocities committed by
Hamas on October 7th were unconscionable
and depraved but the right to
self-defense does not and cannot require
unleashing this humanitarian nightmare
if this Relentless bombardment and Siege
continues they write there will be no
day after for Gaza it will be too late
hundreds of thousands of lives hang in
the balance today they say and in no
other War we can think of in this
Century have civilians been so trapped
without any Avenue or option to escape
to save themselves and their children
and today President Biden warned
Israel's leaders they are losing
international support for the war
Crystal ganing has our top story tonight
the comforting Embrace between a mother
and child in every corner of Gaza there
is destruction and
Devastation we are living through this
distopian
reality that excludes Palestinians from
the basic most basic rights afforded to
all human beings the Palestinian foreign
minister raised what he called an utter
International failure the week the UN
marks 75 years since adopting the
Declaration of Human
Rights water food adequate shelter the
Palestinian red crescent society says
Needs are staggering like like even a
bread it just became a dream to have a a
bread for your family for your children
I've never seen something like this in
my life the World Health Organization
along with the local red crescent were
in Gaza City Saturday to move seriously
injured patients South the wh's Gaza
Envoy expressed frustration with delays
mistreatment of Staff by Israeli forces
and searches even of patients in
ambulances the red crescent is building
a field Hospital in Rafa and hopes to
have the new 50 bed ICU up and running
in a weeks time unfortunately those who
are injured are going to lose their life
if they are not going to get urgent
medical services but this is the
catastrophic situation that all the
people in Gaza are living in many areas
Israel's ambassador to the United
Nations says it's in the process of
opening another Crossing to process Aid
trucks which also carry medical supplies
one still need to make sure of course
that the humanitarian assistance
actually reaches the civilians and not
the Hamas
terrorists without a permanent ceasefire
Aid groups admit there's little they can
do cryistal ganing Global News
London Ukraine's President Vladimir
zalinski fearing his country's fight
against Russia is being forgotten was in
Washington today making an urgent plea
for more military aid zalinsky met with
us lawmakers including President Biden
an aid package that includes money for
Ukraine is being blocked by Republicans
who argue more money should go to
domestic security at the US border with
Mexico it's very important that by the
end of this year we can send very strong
signal of our Unity to the aggressor and
the unity of Ukraine America Europe the
entire Free
World Jackson prco explains why the
stakes are so high for Ukraine back the
White House on his third visit to
Washington as a wartime leader Ukraine's
president is increasingly desperate and
running out of options and people need
to be confident that freedom is secure
and strong enough to win Vladimir
zelinsky's appeal for billions of
dollars in US Aid comes at a critical
time Ukraine's counter offensive is
stalled and Russia is
rearming existing us a will run out by
the end of the year zalinsky warns
Ukraine could lose its fight for
survival the decisions we make now are
going to determine the future for
decades to come meeting with members of
Congress zalinsky outlined the stakes
and Ukraine's military needs but if he
gets the help he can win this War
President Joe Biden has asked lawmakers
to provide a $100 billion Aid package 60
billion is for Ukraine with the rest for
Israel and for US border security
Republicans are blocking it what the
Biden Administration seems to be asking
for is billions of additional dollars
with no appropriate oversight no clear
strategy to win conservative lawmakers
say they want to focus on the Southern
border first as polls show the American
public becoming wary of sending more to
Ukraine the United States did not come
through on this I mean that will
certainly uh you know look send a very
bad signal uh regarding uh American
leadership with time running out
zelinsky's visit was orchestrated as a
last minute push just days before
lawmakers break for the holidays before
they give Putin the greatest Christmas
gift they could possibly give him time
is no longer on Ukraine's side
it can only hope the US still is
Republicans are signaling they're
unlikely to approve more aid until
sometime in January at the White House
zalinski was given a small Lifeline
another $200 million diverted by
President Biden from a special emergency
fund of course that's just a small
fraction of the billions Ukraine says it
needs to win the war Donna Jackson prco
in Washington thanks at the UN climate
conference in Dubai delegates are
working through the night the big
dispute is over four words in the final
agreement a commitment to phase out
fossil fuels many countries including
Canada say that promise is essential if
climate targets are going to be
met and let's deliver and
for our
lead activists and young people at the
cop 28 Summit have been piling on the
pressure this 12-year-old barged onto
the stage with her message and fossil
fuel save our planet and our future the
original draft agreement did not include
any of phasing out fossil fuels and
negotiations on a final agreement are
stretching into the night Redmond
Shannon is following developments for
[Applause]
us dismay from climate action
campaigners as cop 28 winds down in oil
and gasr
Dubai their Fury focused on a draft
agreement text that did not mention
phasing out the use of fossil fuels even
though most expected it to feature for
the very first time in cop Summit
history the draft text that came out
yesterday is unacceptable it's not you
know it's not backed by science climate
experts say phasing out fossil fuels is
fundamental to controlling global
warming also on Tuesday this Summit of
Arab energy ministers in nearby kater
where they agreed that fossil fuels will
be quote pillars of global energy for
many decades to come it's important that
we think about how we get that balance
there are those who want phase out there
are those who want phase down there are
those who want different formulations
and final agreement needs all 198
Nations to sign off on dozens of
contentious agenda items none more so
than the phase out text Canada's
environment Minister are among those
pushing for its inclusion during
Tuesday's marathon of meetings we cannot
let this moment slip away and we cannot
afford to backtrack when a final text is
agreed upon Nations will have just a few
hours to read it through before a vote
organizers can then start thinking about
next year's cop Summit hosted by another
oil and gas Rich Nation
aeran Donna Redmond Shannon
thanks a little later I speak with the
chief scientists for The Nature
Conservancy Canadian Katherine heho
about whether these cop meetings
actually matter and what she thinks has
been accomplished we're learning more
about the new murder charges an Ontario
man is facing in connection with 14
deaths in that Province police alleged
Kenneth law ran several websites that
sold so-called suicide kits Around the
World Eric senson reports on the
allegations and the complex case
allegations of counseling or aiding
suicides against Kenneth law are now in
the realm of mass murder police say the
57-year-old who lived in this Miss Saga
home operated websites to sell a
substance that is it's believed people
used to end their lives it's clearly uh
a significant charge to be laying this
many and and that's not taken lightly by
the investigative team 14 second-degree
murder charges involves 11 Ontario
police forces in communities from the
greater Toronto area to Windsor to
Thunder Bay the victims are male and
female ranging in age from 16 to 36 more
than one was under 18 and all were
residents of Ontario we will not be
naming the names of the victim and how
come the names of alleged murder victims
are normally made public but police are
holding back on that and on a possible
motive evidence has come in uh that
supports the charge of second degree
murder I can't speak to that evidence at
this time to preserve the investigation
I think there's never been any doubt in
my mind that the man is a murderer David
parfett applauds the Ontario charges his
22-year-old son Tom died by suicide in
the UK his case came to light after an
investig ation by the times parfett
believes law coached his son to take his
life he used that for him he he drummed
up custom by being part of a community
that prays on vulnerable people and
seems to get some form of perverse
pleasure from those people harming
themselves police say law shipped 160
packages of sodium nitrate and other
items to be used for self harm across
this country if there's evidence he also
encouraged people to harm themselves
that could bolster the case for murder
says this legal expert if they have
these communications and it's clear that
Mr law was communicating and trying to
influence or convince people who were
maybe thinking about it that may be
compelling evidence to establish he knew
that by shipping this chemical to them
they would use it and therefore die
police alleged that law shipped more
than 1,200 packages to some 40 countries
and say they're working very closely
with law enforcement around the world on
this case Eric senson Global News
Toronto if you or someone you know needs
help you can call or text 988 Canada's
new suicide crisis helpline the service
is available in both English and French
24 hours a day every day a Coroner's
inquest into a death in an Ontario jail
in 2016 has deemed it a homicide Soloman
fakiri had been Shackled pepper sprayed
and covered with a spit Hood face down
on his cell floor the 30-year-old was
accused of stabbing a neighbor and what
his family says was a psychotic episode
he had a combination of schizophrenic
and bipolar symptoms and was awaiting
medical evaluation no charges have been
laid in his
death there were terrifying moments in a
New York neighborhood coming up a
partial collapse of a century old
apartment
building there was concerned people may
have been trapped when the seven-story
apartment building in the Bronx par
ially collapsed firefighters in New York
say no bodies have been found two people
have been treated for minor injuries
repairs were underway on the outside of
the building when it began crumbling
last night and the cause of the collapse
is still under
investigation in Spain police are
calling a massive seizure of cocaine a
major blow to Europe's most powerful
distribution networks 11,000 kilos of
cocaine from South America was
confiscated in two separate police
stings the drugs were hidden between
pieces of Frozen two and in false
bottoms of shipping containers 20 people
linked to two criminal organizations
from the Balkans have been arrested
still ahead the takeaways from cop 28 as
countries Feud over the fate of fossil
[Music]
fuels we cannot wait for speeches when
the sea is rising around us all the time
climate Mobility must come to the
Forefront that is the foreign minister
of tuvalu two years ago standing in the
oceans addressing the cop 26 conference
for years Pacific island nations like
his have been sounding the alarm about
climate change and rising sea levels
they are living with the consequences
well today at the cop 28 meeting in
Dubai they are exhausted oil producing
countries who profit from the fossil
fuel industry carry so much weight it
feels like a Battleground over the
planet's future we feeling the weight
not just of the negotiations but of
everything that is taken to come up to
this point because it's not just about
what happens here it's about all of the
meetings that we've been to before this
it's about the inter sessionals it's
about the working group we've already
fed so much into only to come into
negotiations and be blocked so it's
tiring and exhausting and it's
disappointing well with me now is
Professor Katherine heho she is an
atmospheric scientist and chief
scientist for The Nature Conservancy
Professor thanks for being here fossil
fuels we know are the biggest source of
greenhouse gas emissions so when you see
all of this arguing at the cop meeting
about the words phase out fossil fuels
where does it leave you well what a lot
of people don't realize is that just two
or three years ago the word fossil fuels
had never even been used in the United
Nations climate negotiations so the fact
that there is so much pressure to not
only include the word but specifically
phasing out coal oil and gas this may
surprise you but it represents
tremendous progress and growing Global
awareness that we need to act now well I
know you are an optimist which is which
is wonderful you know about 80,000
people are registered uh for the cop 28
conference business Executives
apparently outnumber the country
delegates and the cop 28 president is
also chair of the UAE state-owned Oil
Company it is hard not to look at all
that and wonder what is the point of
these meetings oh yes I I completely
agree what I'm encouraged by is the fact
that these climate action meetings are
now happening much more at the local
scale so there was an Africa climate
Summit a Latin am America climate Summit
climate week in New York City there are
all kinds of summits and organizations
and conferences and meetings happening
below the global scale where people are
really getting things done and that's
the way it needs to be we can't do this
alone but I know that we can do it
together and that means every single one
of us has a role to play and I know that
you think there are some positives that
came out of this cop meeting uh can you
give us some of them yes there
absolutely are so the biggest benefit to
these meetings in my opinion is that it
offers people a chance to get together
and talk and share and learn and grow
and collaborate together so for example
coming out of this meeting we saw
multiple countries including Colombia
joined the fossil fuel nonproliferation
treaty we saw big announcements on
investment in Ocean Solutions
sustainable agriculture and reducing
agricultural emissions we saw a loss and
damage fund for the most vulnerable
countries in the world finalized and of
course we announced as a country our cap
on oil and gas emissions which is an
essential part of bringing our own
National budget in line with the Paris
targets you know the next cop meeting is
going to be in aeran next year a country
whose main source of Revenue is oil and
gas what's up with
that well um what I heard is that uh
because the United Nations negotiations
have to be
unanimous that when one country says we
don't agree that means they have to keep
going until they find something they can
agree on and Russia did not want to hold
this conference is what I heard in any
country that opposed the war on Ukraine
um I I feel like holding these in remote
locations that are oil and gas
strongholds is not the right message to
be sending it is not productive we need
to be looking at action and personally
if I was in charge of making the
decision I would pick the host country
based on how much they had accomplished
so they could show off what they were
doing and help encourage more change in
other countries well that seems sensible
as you always are Professor Katherine
hey ho thank
you thank you thank you for having
me next the growing pressure on Canada
to sanction people with ties to
Hamas the agony of families whose loved
ones are still being held hostage in
Gaza never eases every day they plead
for their release and now some have come
to Ottawa they joined a coalition of
human rights groups and MPS asking the
federal government to sanction dozens of
people with ties to Hamas Abigail Bean
spoke with one family about what they
are
enduring nrod is my twin brother but he
also my best friend nimod is a normal
child like every other child in the
world Nimrod Cohen is just 19 years old
kidnapped by Hamas October 7th his
family has no idea if he's okay or even
alive when you know your loved one is
dead as cruel as it sound you know it's
the end we don't know if it's the end or
not and when the day come and we will
return if we will return that's a big
question in what condition physically
and psychologically will return could I
have my boy back as a normal
boy it's a question that you know drills
in your
mind Romy and Yehuda Cohen are in Ottawa
and along with human rights groups are
calling on the Canadian government to do
more magnitsky sanctions whereby We join
our allies in targeting the perpetrators
former Justice Minister Irwin Cotler is
calling on Ottawa to sanction architects
of the October 7th Massacre and list
Iran's revolutionary guard as terrorists
we forget that it is Iranian leadership
that has armed and trained and financed
and incentivized and even celebrated
these Mass atrocities while they worry
about the conditions and torture Nimrod
May face the cohens say Hamas is
inflicting psychological torture on
hostage families their lives broken we
hope that by telling our personal
stories people will connect and feel us
because watching it on TV maybe at the
beginning and now it's more than 2
months since you know you see it you
feel bad and you keep you keep on and we
want people to remember this this is our
message there are maybe I hope still
alive and we can fight for them never
ends since October 7th it's been 67 days
for Romy it just feels like one that
never ends Abigail Bean Global News
Ottawa and that is global national for
this Tuesday I'm Donna freezen tonight's
here at Canada is this beautiful view of
Ottawa that's the shadow laor on the
right we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers global.com
and thanks for watching Hope to see you
here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye